we're moving into interaction right so
we've covered the IDS and campus of
differentiation in situation already we
have them in our minds so having worked
out how it is different share
expeditions we can just go straight into
the grading we don't need to learn any
lessons every people to know about
integration is founded upon what you
already know about differentiation so
each of these is a statement that we've
already established and we have a
corresponding statement in integration
that we can conclude on the basis of
these these Crawler easily so since by
definition the derivative of e to the X
is just e to the X that means that the
integral of e to the X if just reversing
the process is going to be e DX will
then our constant of integration right
if you have another base then some more
terms are gonna get in there we can get
that I didn't write them in the water
again so you can see here because
differentiation integration they're
kinda like a balance right was she just
your three you come back the other way
you don't know what that constant was in
this case it was zero but it could have
been two or three or five hundred or PI
etc so we'll just have a plus it or some
mysterious Lauren thank you like here
you can see if I put a media function in
there so a very very simple kind of
function you can see that the derivative
is come out the front this is just like
the simplest version of chain rule that
you could possibly do right so the
derivative of your inner function your
inside functions a quiet pops out the
front so then if I'm integrating this
same guy just like we tell them what
we're doing
age of differentiation for polynomials
right instead of multiplying I am going
to divide
and of course the caustic comes along
for the ride okay one of the great
things and this is it's you know very
easy to verify okay we use we've got
differentiation riding our heads okay so
we can just give this a go oh yeah this
a man come out the front cancel and
you're back to exactly what you all
right before okay last one just to
generalize this pack a little bit
further if it Monday X must be at the
top just some other theme okay if you
see at the front of your exponential
function you're trying to integrate if
you see something in this form or
something that isn't too different from
it then you know what you're going to
integrate up into was this this is where
you came from right and this is where
you ended up so you're gonna get your e
to the power of X plus think I get them
again you can differentiate to check so
just looking at some very few examples I
don't need to give you much of a tip
from the first one because it is it's
already sample okay we're looking at
sector one have a look at this if I'm
integrating e to the 2x minus 3 okay you
can either you knew one of two things
you can either just appeal to this rule
right if it's in your head that's fine I
do believe it will be on your reference
sheet that you've already seen once
before so you can use that if you want
just personally though I actually prefer
a slightly longer way which might seem
less efficient but I'll try and justify
why I like it you send it okay what I'd
like to try and do is get this in this
form okay I want to try and get the
derivative out the fun I am really doing
reverse chain rule so I want to make the
chain rule obvious so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to write this as the
integral of 2 e to the 2x minus 3 with
respect to X right there's that F dash e
to the F X but of course you can't just
multiply things by 2 just cause you feel
like it right so to make sure I haven't
actually changed this term to compensate
I multiply by 1/2 1/2 of the to mean
there's a net change of energy okay
so now that I've got that there the half
is outside that process of integration
right that one over 2 that's the one
over a that's where it comes from
okay and then this is going to become e
to the 2x now the advantage of doing
this the reason why I try to do this is
because if you get in your head
oh it's chain rule will reverse chain
rule then when you meet things which are
not just oh it's another rule you will
be more well equipped and will be more
in your brains so for instance right
here I'm not just coming around from
have a whole function right what
function do I want here in order to be F
that I want to X don't right so as it
happens the numerical stuff here is the
same right
I want to X there that's the F - I'm
expecting e to the x squared plus 150x
but to compensate for the two that i
unsurveyed easily inserted I will
multiply by 1/2 just like I did before
so now that F - that whole piece it
disappears when I get to the integral
right so all I will be left with is a
half e to the N squared plus 1 okay and
just to satisfy myself let's let's just
differentiate and double check aha e to
the x squared plus 1 plus the constant
the habits this is generally what I do
to X the derivative of this guy comes
out the front which you max right and
then that's the inside function the
outer function is an indicator what
happens when you differentiate where
this guy's nothing happens he just
becomes his same old self and of course
we know what happens to the constant
okay so cancel there is the integrand
just like a no happy okay does that make
sense
now admittedly I mean simple examples to
begin with this this guy here this is
the thing you're looking for if you see
f dash in there you know oh this came
from chain rule
sometimes it's reasonably obvious
sometimes they'll literally just hand
hand f dash to you okay more often
nothing you sort of have to muck about a
little bit to make
that's exactly what you want and then
off you go and integrate question okay
so it kind of depends on what kind of
more it is so for instance this is a
good example of more than okay so it's
like huh I knew what I was expecting at
the front I didn't get what I was
expecting
so what do I do in this okay now
interestingly just because I thought up
in this example at the moment you are
not equipped to deal with this bullet
okay because watch what happens I want
to get toward something I can integrate
this I know how into it right so I'm
gonna separate some things out I want to
do this I'm gonna say well there's this
guy right and then there's this guy
and they're both being integrated you're
happy with that so that's good
this is a problem I already know how to
solve and then you would tackle a this
guy's separately okay
not just at the present moment we don't
have the technique and we haven't
developed them yet so to be the spy or
these are because doesn't fit into any
of the things that we know of it there's
no thing out the front which is even
remotely close to F - so you can't you
can't multiply by an X and then divide
by mix out here
that's variable if you can't walk around
with those are the same way you can with
constants okay but this is the strategy
I would take if you've got extra stuff
in there then you better get that extra
stuff out of the way so you can find the
bits that you need okay it's worth
mentioning you sometimes give the
reverse problem you sometimes the I
don't have enough stuff in here and you
have to do that trick where just like
when we are just like we do have
something like this and we say how do
you rationalize this yeah you have to
insert something that is completely not
there and then it just all comes out in
the wash sometimes you have to add
something in that it's not there those
are harder tables we would get to
overtime okay essentially though at the
moment we're looking for something that
we've fairly easy to trace
consider all right